as much as we want to believe we choose
movies because of intriguing stories
instead of ALS stars that often isn't
the case and casting the right person
for a role means choosing an actor who
can pull off the character convincingly
and be bankable enough to sell lots of
tickets but Hollywood isn't perfect and
there are times they get it wrong or
pretty close to it these hit films
nearly went in very different directions
with leading roles only to make a clich
casting change that made them the
blockbusters they are today Liam Neeson
in Lincoln now that he starred in three
taken movies it can be easy to forget
that Liam Neeson is a serious traumatic
actor with an Oscar nom for his
performance in Schindler's List and
while his appearance and life's too
short proves he's not nearly as
humorless as his characters on screen
sometimes as he actor who knows when a
part just isn't right after the success
of Schindler's List director Steven
Spielberg taught Neeson to lead another
dramatic historical project Lincoln I
like her changes now Neeson admitted to
GQ of the table read for the film I read
very very poorly by any standards but
then some people come up afterward and
say oh you're made to play Lincoln I was
just cringing with embarrassment
ultimately Neeson stepped away in the
POW into Daniel day-lewis who won an
Oscar for the role shall we stop this
bleeding Neeson said I was thrilled that
Daniel played em and when I saw the film
I was like he's in Abraham Lincoln this
is perfect David Schwimmer in men in
black men in black further cemented Will
Smith has one of the biggest movie stars
of the 90s adding another hit to an
incredible run that also included bad
boys and Independence Day his
performance was spot-on in what might
have otherwise been a ridiculous alien
flick for kids like if say Ross from
friends had tried to pull it off you
know the difference is between you and
me
I make this look good David Schwimmer
was offered the role but turned it down
because he was already starring in and
directing the dramedy since you've been
gone if you feel bad for shrim are
missing out on a colossal payday
remember that Smith passed on playing
neo in the matrix to play the lead in
wild wild west we all make mistakes
Frank Sinatra and Dirty Harry until a
few years ago the rumor that Frank
Sinatra was cast to play the title role
in the 1971 cop drama Dirty Harry was
just that a rumor but in 2015 Academy
award-winning director William Friedkin
confirmed on Alec Baldwin's podcast
here's the thing
but before Eastwood it was all blue eyes
my producer guy named Phil D'Antoni he
and I were going to do Dirty Harry with
Frank Sinatra
and then Sinatra pulled out according to
Yahoo movies film critic tiburce book
gods like us explained Sinatra's
reasoning as a broken wrist sustained
during The Manchurian Candidate eight
years earlier men that old blue eyes
couldn't hold the heavy Magnum pistol
comfortably far better known as a singer
Sinatra earned acclaim as an actor but
tough-guy parts weren't exactly his
forte you've got to ask yourself one
question do I feel lucky
well do you punk Britney Spears in the
notebook the movie that launched the
ryan gosling's movie career almost never
happened
the notebook hit a major hiccup during
filming when Gosling asked the director
to bring in a different actress because
he wasn't getting along with co-star
Rachel McAdams director Nick Cassavetes
told vh1 he's doing a scene with Rachel
and he says would you take her out of
here and bring in another actress to
read off camera with me I can't do it
with her I'm just not getting anything
from this we went into a room with the
producer they started screaming and
yelling at each other I walked out in
the end the Gosling and McAdams shelved
the differences but before they made up
Gosling screen-tested with an old friend
from the Mickey Mouse Club
Britney Spears Gosling confirmed Spears
was up for the role telling eat see I
hands Cena really since she was about 12
we were both 12 so she's grown up but
she was really good actually
pleasantries aside the driving force
behind the notebook success was the
acting and an inexperienced Spears
likely couldn't have carried the role
Molly Ringwald and pretty woman when it
came time to cast pretty woman
production are to choose between two
incredible actors responding to
questions on a reddit AMA Molly Ringwald
admitted she was once under
consideration for the lead role in the
movie with credits like The Breakfast
Club I'm pretty in pink to a named few
could contend that Ringwald wouldn't
have done a fantastic job but Julia
Roberts ended up winning the part and
walking away with the movie my employee
even Ringwald agrees saying Julia
Roberts is what makes a movie it was her
parts every actor hopes for a part that
lets him shine like that Tom Selleck in
Raiders of the Lost Ark George Lucas who
co-wrote the Steven Spielberg directed
Raiders of the Lost Ark didn't 1
Harrison Ford's a star as Indiana Jones
in a making-of featurette Spielberg
remembered I had just seen a cut of
Empire Strikes Back and said to George
that's Indiana Jones right up there han
Solo why can't he do it and the Lucas
told Spielberg he's identified as Han
Solo let's leave him as han Solo and I
said yeah but he's an actor actors play
hundreds of different characters in it
Ford was cast but only as a replacement
for their first choice Tom
who had already been cast as in
de-select old David Letterman that CBS
made him turn down the role in favor of
their show magnum p.i
[Music]
select old Leatherman and the more they
held out the offer and talked to the
network the more the network said no
eventually the network of course being
CBS but at this point is impossible to
imagine anyone but Ford cracking that
web Eric Stoltz in Back to the Future
Michael J Fox he was booked solid at the
time with his hit NBC sitcom family ties
came very close to not getting his
big-screen breakout in Back to the
Future forced to go without his first
pick for leading man director Robert
Zemeckis originally cast Eric Stoltz in
the role of Marty McFly production began
with Stoltz playing Marty but the crew
knew something just wasn't right and
Zemeckis worked out to deal with them BC
for Fox to film around his family ties
scheduled and replaced thoughts had
already filmed the number of scenes
Stoltz took it hard but in 2016
eagle-eyed fans noticed something Stoltz
made the final cuts in their scene when
Marty punches Biff in the diner that
Stoltz throwing the punch thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]